[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
good morning good morning good morning
[Music]
lindsey graham
seems really really really [ __ ] upset
that white men in this country are so
oppressed
all that brett kavanaugh he had such a
bad time they held him accountable for
all his actions oh
it's so sad those united states senators
on the judiciary committee
asked him about about him him sexually
assaulting
women when there were allegations
against him shut the [ __ ] up lindsey
graham
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
chuck grassley
they they really they really do hate
they hate that the constitution is a
living document they [ __ ] hate that
don't they i mean they [ __ ] hate it
it is something that they despise that
the constitution
would be a living document
that lives and breathes that can change
we can change the constitution it's
called an amendment
there are a couple of them
there's two that they love right they
get to this first two amendments the
first amendment and the second amendment
they don't they don't really know what
the [ __ ] those amendments say
but they they they get about to the
second amendment and then realize that
the constitution is living and it can be
changed
lindsey graham chuck grassley
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
lindsey graham pretending like
that it was some kind of
left-wing movement to get rid of his
candidate
listen the president of the united
states
said when he was the candidate
that he was going to pick a black woman
so that the court looked more like
america which it should and i hope
i mean my hope is when katangi brown
jackson has asked if she'll vote to ex
if she would vote to expand the supreme
court i hope she says hell yeah
[ __ ] expand that [ __ ]
it's it's it's never been more obvious
now than ever that there needs to be an
expansion of the supreme court and we
need to fundamentally change this
politics [ __ ] should we should we have
the senate actually
you know do the whole judiciary
committee where they confirm a nominee
absolutely
absolutely
fine
perfectly fine
should the president of the united
states get to select a pool of nominees
fine sure
but i think we need a fundamental change
at the supreme court
this [ __ ] is absolutely ridiculous
ridiculous that we have to sit here and
listen to these old white ball sacks
whine and complain about other white
ball sacks not getting a fair shot in
the judiciary committee
as josh hawley hasn't spoke yet but is
going to talk about child porn the
entire time because josh hawley sums for
some [ __ ] reason some [ __ ] reason
i can't figure it out yet
josh hawley is obsessed
absolutely obsessed
with porn
specifically in this case child porn he
is obsessed with it
they can't he can't get his mind off of
porn
i wonder
i just i'm just wondering
it's just me just be wondering
snowballing here
what if we go to some computer repair
shops
try to see if i don't know josh hawley
has some
laptop there or something
i don't know
maybe we should
welcome welcome to the tony michaels
podcast every single weekday this is a
special episode
this is a special
episode
because it's episode 100
100 episodes of the tony michaels
podcast
the other announcement that we have big
announcement this morning is usually i
say it's every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch which is the
case this morning we are live right now
on youtube twitter and twitch
but we are also live on facebook
that dreaded meta
that's right
we are broadcasting live over on
facebook
so if you are joining us from facebook
thank you very much for watching the
tony michaels podcast tune in every
single weekday every one of them monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
right here on youtube twitter twitch and
now might as touch facebook page
i mean as long as you know i don't get
too crazy
as long as i don't get too crazy
the myzealis brothers may let me still
broadcast
on facebook's on their facebook page as
long as you don't get too crazy also if
you're on youtube know that we have the
super chat thank you mj for the super
sticker we really do appreciate it
uh everyone's here this morning a lot of
new faces and
a lot of faces we recognize debbie from
salt lake cathy robin kelly is here
crystal from facebook's here mel mary
miles from facebook is here jaclyn's
here
mayo is here on twitch hello mayo out
there on twitch we got a lot of
listeners a lot of listeners
mj says happy100 thank you thank you
very much for 100 episodes
we really do appreciate you guys tuning
in and listening and participating in
the chat
in the chat you guys can chat over on
youtube
you can chat on facebook or on twitch
twitter is a little different
see they used to have like periscope
over on twitter and for what whatever
reason when twitter you know did their
thing with periscope or they did away
with periscope and they i don't know
what the hell they did i don't know i'm
not i'm not an i.t genius at all maybe
we'll ask gabe when he comes in what the
hell twitter did he'll know more than me
he probably won't know because it's
technical stuff but hey maybe he'll know
maybe we'll ask him
but for whatever reason the the the
twitter comments don't push through
uh let's see here we have marianne here
mary here
uh
we have a lot of crystal over from
facebook thank you guys richard uh
brandon thank you for joining us
over on facebook
again chris is here you guys can tune in
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central right here on youtube twitter
twitch and now midas touch facebook page
as long as they don't get too crazy you
know you know i get banned over on
is it easy to get banned on facebook i'm
not on facebook a lot
i mean we will be now every single
weekday two hours a day that's right
folks over on facebook this show is two
hours every single weekday here's what
we do just to give you an idea in case
we have any really new listeners out
there we go through all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends we try to
figure out what the hell is going on in
the world
break that down
with you know that tony michael style
commentary i don't know if you notice
but i like to speak my mind
and you know we might drop the f-bomb
now and then
every now and a [ __ ] again we may
drop the f-bomb
so thank you thank you for joining us if
you're a new listener out there
again
join us every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central youtube twitter
twitch and now minus touch facebook page
let's i think i think we should go
probably
uh to the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends gabe's gonna be joining us at the
bottom of the first hour
um to give us some more commentary we're
probably gonna be talking about
the uh senate judiciary hearing that
they're having this morning on catanji
brown jackson
the the the brand new
supreme court justice there's no way
she's not gonna be supreme court justice
by the way that they would love they
would love to be able to stop that
nomination but they can't they can't
that's why they're so [ __ ] pissed off
it's because it took brett kavanaugh
crying in his beer and [ __ ] about how he
was there he sexually assaulted someone
i can't believe someone brought that up
in my in my supreme court
nomination hearings
also they're talking about how katangi
brown jackson has been bought and paid
for this is all [ __ ] projection
holy [ __ ] absolute projection everyone
knows that there's been dark money who
paid off brett kavanaugh's debt
plus white men don't don't get a fair
shot in this country the [ __ ] out of
here lindsey graham all right let's go
to the tweety tweets and trendy trends
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome to the shitless
round-up part of the show where we round
up all the tweety tweets and eternity
trends of the day
we love that we rub we love to round up
the tweety tweets and eternity trends to
know what's going on out there in the
[ __ ] world
so all of you on facebook you probably
go through your facebook feed i'm not
i'm not familiar with it
but we go through the twitter trends
here on the tony michaels podcast so if
you don't want to go on twitter
you're able to just come here and every
day and figure out what the trendy
trends are and the tweety tweets and
we'll run through those sumbitches
so let's let's get started here cause we
you know this this is gonna be um
a very a very uh
heavy day
on on on the [ __ ] list roundup for the
supreme court the supreme court
uh
let's see here oh here here no no casler
uh tweets earlier i feel very
responsible for josh hawley being in the
senate i feel terrible about it josh
hawley played a central role in creating
if not the darkest day in american
history one of the darkest days in
american history
that is a quote from former senator john
c danforth who is a republican from
missouri now i i'm from missouri and
josh hawley is
is the senator the sad senator the great
state of missouri he doesn't live here
and hasn't lived here in a long time
everyone knows that but senator john
danforth former senator john danforth
does live here he does live in missouri
he's from missouri lives in missouri and
you know the issue with uh danforth and
what he's uh the quote here that noel
has uh posted here on twitter is that
senator john danforth
is the reason why josh hawley is a
senator in the first place in missouri
danforth put his weight
behind uh josh hawley and that is why
danvoorth has kinda kind of been a king
maker
when it comes to republican politics in
the state of missouri
and
unfortunately he put his weight behind
josh hawley and then josh hawley um
turned out to be a nazi you know
pumping his fist it's all the
insurrectionist
and danforth kind of regrets that
decision
so no points that out here thinks no i
would i normally i i give credit but
noel's got his comments turned off here
i would imagine
that's because a bunch of maga trolls a
bunch of josh holly manga trolls you
know you know the the white supremacists
are really pissed off and noel castler
is pointing out the truth um christopher
uh had this video he says um
um this is the commentary with it josh
holly right now this is josh hawley
right now if you want to take a look
he's spreading gasoline oh uh
oh yeah that's probably josh holly
every single day i keep asking this
question and i'm gonna keep asking it
over and over and over again why is josh
holly so obsessed with pornography
he is absolutely obsessed obsessed with
pornography
can't get it out of his skull i don't
know
i don't know maybe maybe just maybe
josh holly needs to focus on a few more
things
rather than pornography um here is uh uh
marcia marsha blackburn
of tennessee tennessee you really need
to get your [ __ ] together here
um a lot better than she did her hair
does she own a [ __ ] brush number one
um here's marsha blackburn
and let's read what ron has wrote here
uh ron writes marsha blackburn in
discussing scotus nominee jackson says
she wants to know her position on the
constitutionality
unsound decision of great griswold
versus khan
the decision of griswold versus khan
from what i understand is the 19 i think
it's to believe that's a 1965 decision
that made it okay for married couples
to use birth control are you are you
listening to what i'm saying the 1965
decision
supreme court decision
that made it
legal
for married a married couple
to use birth control protected it as a
right as it were you know before that it
was you know kind of up in the air right
and this has tennesseans confused she
says
let's listen to this bonehead it's only
29 seconds
really honestly is this is this a hairdo
or i'm not sure i i figured she'd want
to brush her hair a little better man
it's just me
constitutionally unsound rulings like
griswold versus connecticut kilo versus
city of new london and nfib versus
sibelius confused tennesseans and left
congress wondering who gave the court
permission to bypass our system of
checks and balances
see that is the system of checks and
balances you dumb [ __ ]
that's the whole point the whole point
is the court gets to rule in decisions
that are brought to the court
that's the whole point of the court
what don't these people understand about
what a check and balance is
they say these words they say these
words like constitution and alien sound
constitution
and protected rights
and and checks and balances and
amendments
they say all these things but they don't
[ __ ] clearly understand what they
mean
i will give ron credit here
thanks for your tweet
um i said this was my comment
anyone tell these [ __ ] momos that
contraception prevents abortion they're
gonna go on and on and on and on about
this
with katangi jackson right
and they're not they're not just
attacking they're not just attacking
abortion here
right they're attacking birth control
are you are you are you listening
because they not only want to take your
[ __ ] liberty away from you for your
body
but they also want to take away your
your right to prevent an abortion
to prevent your right to prevent an
abortion you got it
they are so [ __ ] twisted up
so twisted up in their minds i've never
really understood this why republicans
or conservatives or christians or
pro-lifers aren't like staunchly for
for birth control like birth control is
the the number one prevention of
abortion if you hate abortion so [ __ ]
bad like if you're so against it
you just can't [ __ ] stand it
wouldn't you have some sort of policy
that was pro preventing it like you know
contraception
what they're saying is they don't want
you to have sex
they want to dictate to you who you can
who you can't when you can when you
can't if you can have sex
that's the road they're on
that's a road they've been on for
[ __ ] decades though they just always
thin veil it with this [ __ ]
conservatism [ __ ]
and they've never been conservative a
conservative if a conservative would
would consider contraception
like literally that's what they would do
a liberal would be like ah [ __ ] it you
know just
the hell with it
we'll just play the numbers here no a
conservative would would
would try to prevent a pregnancy if they
didn't want one
oh jesus they really they really are
i call them [ __ ] momos they really
are momos
okay
uh ben my zealous uh was uh uh
quote tweeting the same one griswold
versus connecticut uh does
does constitution protect the right of
marital privacy against states
restrictions on couples ability to be
counseled in the use of contraceptions
that was the question being asked
in griswold versus connecticut basically
can married people
use birth control
that was the question
can can a married couple make sure that
if they [ __ ] they can try to not have a
baby and the supreme court in 1965 said
yes
yes you're married you can [ __ ] and try
to prevent yourself
from from having a pregnancy you can do
that that is a that is a thing that
happens in this country and you have the
right
i hear blackburn he says griswold is
constitutionally unsound and kentangi
jackson must answer for it
because that's what they're saying
they're basically saying a decision that
the supreme court made in 1965 is
katangi brown jackson's fault
like somehow she's responsible for that
decision
you know
if katangi brown jackson
had a history of criminal assault
especially criminal sexual assault i
would i would i would make sure that the
democrats brought that [ __ ] up
you're not gonna hear once you're not
gonna hear [ __ ] one allegation of
katangi brown jackson sexually
assaulting someone not [ __ ] one
they're gonna try to make her answer
for a supreme court decision that that
gave the the right that was already
given to married couples to prevent a
pregnancy by the way of contraception
and birth control
the [ __ ] out of here with this
[ __ ] this week's gonna be fun folks
i mean for me at least
this is the kind of commentary that i
like when they're going after your
liberty when they're going after your
freedom
when they're when they're when they're
not even not even hiding it saying the
quiet part out loud oh baby do i love to
beat the drum
i love beating that drum because that's
who they are
that's who they are last week we watched
a goddamn clip of some [ __ ]
uh uh uh bret michaels or or or
some kind of wannabe with sunglasses and
long hair he's america first nazi what
are these nick fuentes nazis
talking to lauren winsk or whatever the
[ __ ] that nazi's name is
talking about how women are currency
that's that's what they that's what they
want that's what they believe women are
not humans
women should not have rights they should
not have autonomy not even not even
autonomy their bodies they're way long
past women having autonomy of their
bodies
they want women to have no rights and no
liberty they want them to be property
they're fascist that's what they are
they're they're they're fascist and
they're showing you that like they're
outright showing you that you have
marjorie taylor greene
and the lieutenant governor of idaho
attending these nazi rallies he's
america first nick fuentes nazi rallies
these pro-putin uh nazi rallies
to try to take rights away from women
and make them property that's what they
want um i said this morning also about
this katangi contangi brown jackson
hearing
pasty white bigots in the senate big
jelly of katanji brown jackson that's
really the rub too that was the thing
with lindsey graham this morning maybe
we'll find a clip of that son of a [ __ ]
i'm talking about uh you know he's a
real butthurt real butthurt
over this stuff
okay at some other news you guys know we
try to follow um we had dakota adams on
our show and tasha adams as well which
is the estranged son and the estranged
wife
of stuart rhodes the founder of the oath
keepers who is charged with
uh seditious conspiracy um hugo has a
new uh story here sources tell me doj
and january 6 committee has received
hours
hours it says of non-public footage
a proud boy's head tario enrique tario
you know he was just arrested and
indicted on conspiracy charges and oath
keepers head stuart rhodes
from gold crest films crew this was the
documentary crew that caught them in the
parking garage we played that little
clip last week of enrique tario and
stuart rhodes meeting in a parking
garage
uh trying to uh conspire on their
sedition and their treason of the united
states and that the film crew that
followed them before the capital attack
so uh we will try to keep keep up on
that it sounds like uh
you know that that film was kind of put
out uh a while back
but uh
gabe actually gabe is here
uh
good morning gabe good morning uh you
dug up you dug up we're talking about
the uh the gold crest films right now
we'll go back to uh brown jackson here
in a minute i want to find a clip of uh
lindsey graham complaining about how
white men have an unfair shot in this
country
but but anyways anyways uh back to the
uh go crest films tario uh stuart rhodes
uh documentary here
you dug up the little clip that we
showed last week of them meeting in the
parking garage where they're shaking
hands before they conspire to overturn
the constitution of the united states it
sounds like um that the doj in january 6
has
received at least by hugo's report here
has received hours is what they say of
non-public footage now you're you're you
have been in the business of filming
things and stuff
uh and we filmed a lot of things a lot
of times you just keep the camera
rolling right you never know what you're
gonna capture exactly so it's very
unclear um
at least by the reporting so far of how
many hours but depending on the the
actual camera that they were using it
could be
it could be
dozens of hours is it i mean yeah i mean
there there could be uh yeah dozens of
hours i mean like we don't know what the
because you know if this was if the
intention was to make a documentary
right like one
you're trying to capture as much as you
can because you don't know when you're
gonna cut to this or you're like oh
gonna do it like a little
talking head moment you're going to go
to like some conversation that was
happening or some moment in time
and
it's always especially when filming it's
always bet like the
the the best policy is just to keep
things rolling right like
uh memory is such a cheap asset or
commodity in terms of recording nowadays
that it's like swap one card and swap
the other card in as long as i have a
battery and i can keep things going
then then we're good to go and because
it didn't used to be that way it used to
be you'd actually cut it on on film so
that was very valuable right i mean yeah
it depends like you you know you had
super eight all the way back and then
you had like uh then you had vhs then
you had high eight which is like smaller
you know high eight is the type of tape
that the
uh
tommy lee yeah anderson tape if anyone
has seen them right right clicks that's
where the that's the uh that step tape
and then
and then obviously it gets cheaper and
cheaper as we like advanced technology
gets cheaper and cheaper to uh to have
more
uh memory on a smaller device look at
your phone as an example right so it's a
very cheap thing to have where you're
like oh yeah
512 one gig whatever swap it in swap it
out change the battery and we can keep
rolling all day so in other words i i
may be in in the correct area that
they're who it could be it could be a
lot depending on when they actually
started filming when they started
that's the big thing yeah we don't know
when when they started we know that
obviously there was a second documentary
crew that was happening that was filming
roger stone
and those were some of those things were
released when uh the the washington post
article came out now and that that's
that's the one where we showed um in the
interview with dakota where it had the
it showed ryder stone's phone and he had
tario uh he had stuart rhodes there were
several other uh joe greenberg joe
greenberg which is significant in
another case yeah there was a
palm palm beach uh super pac as well and
uh whoever is in his friends of stone
aka fos so whoever's in that telegram
group i don't know
but yeah
so it's actually a group of people that
uh friends of stone is what they right
is what they call it that yeah yeah yeah
yeah that makes sense but that's that's
the documentary is that the same gold
crest films
or do we know no no no no that's a
totally different documentary different
documentary so they were just they just
happened to be running in parallel with
each other so i don't know if those
crews one ever crossed over and caught
each other on on camera
or what was happening or if they
coordinate or what have you i just know
that they're still working on that roger
stone footage
to release um because i know if you go
to their website they're like coming
soon
um and the washington post article was
like hey we got this footage and
everyone's like wait what like nobody
really knew about it right until this
article came out and the same thing
because it existed it was out there in
the space you just no one really paid
attention or put the two together right
like right right like really like really
in the public sphere like a few
reporters reported on it that i think
that video
um that you unearthed it originally came
out it was posted on twitter
um
not much longer after january 6 right i
mean yeah it was sometime at the end of
the month you know channel 4 had a had
footage and then it you know somebody
had a link to their youtube and then
that video had been taken down i don't
know if that was for like uh legal
reasons they're like take that down
right now because we need to use it as
evidence right and we don't want to have
it out there for anyone to do because
it's just that one little clip where
they're kind of meeting right right
we're saying much in that clip other
than you know this is who this is this
is who that is right um and outside of
the you know whatever i forget what
what uh rhodes said to tario but he was
like you know good to meet or like
pleasure to meet you and he's like
likewise like right they knew of each
other right but they hadn't lived enough
right they're cordially enough to like
greet each other and clearly there was
some coordinated effort for all the
people involved were you like well yeah
because it wasn't just the oath keepers
and proud boys it was right the latinos
for trump leader was there um there was
a couple other group leaders
that's right who is who uh who took the
mantra all the proud are the excuse me
the oath keepers and then has since uh
relinquished it and dropped her
candidacy for whatever race she thought
she was running
in texas so there were several players
at that meeting and i i think that's
going to be significant uh in why roger
stone is such an important part of the
actual
guilty plea of joshua james who is one
of stuart rhodes foot soldiers in the
oath keepers who was providing roger
stone
personal protection on the day of
january 6 i believe that's going to be
very significant oh yeah very very
significant gabe did you know that we
are on facebook today we are in the
metaverse
is that what you call it move over zuck
we're in the metaverse baby i just want
to point out though episode 100 what a
day what an episode to break that's
going to facebook huh i think so i think
so i don't know many years after
facebook launch we're finally in it
right yeah but we're finally episode 100
uh meta
welcomed us with open arms maybe yeah i
don't know i don't know what our digital
cell we have right now on like for us
this is video on facebook we are avatars
this is a digital space we're living our
best lives we cannot die it's right
right exactly do you sound like you're
quoting someone is that a quote from
somewhere because
it sounds like a really shitty speech
anyways um
anyone anyone out there that are on
facebook that are new watchers and new
listeners here gabe is the executive
producer and the co-host and every once
in a while the guy who can't run the
microphone um he he helps us write
produce uh edit video all the graphics
that you see um he is
most likely responsible for if it
doesn't look good it probably is me if
it looks great it probably is him on the
graphics and the art so uh everyone i
wanna i wanna introduce gabe sanchez
even though this is episode 100 to all
those all those new listeners out there
uh so as as we tick through and you guys
keep listening gabe will join us um
throughout the week and again we're
every single weekday yeah monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific youtube twitter twitch
but now we get to say facebook i don't
know if that's good or not facebook you
know as long as as long as
as long as we don't get them banned over
there right yeah i mean i don't know we
say something i used to i used to work
for a technology company that would that
would sell a an app on on facebook and
having those sales calls with older
people who are decision makers in the
sales process they'd be like
so what are you again and i'm like you
know legitimately like calling these
people you know and they'd be like um
you know it's a facebook app or do this
whatever he's like you're on you're on
the facebook so like facebook page and
i'm like no not it's not the same thing
kind of but like difference no own own
thing going on they're like
facebook
huh
pretty cool and i was like yeah so you
want to buy and like no
that's you know you you have to find the
right people at the right time to make
that sale but sometimes like this type
of [ __ ] that they would say would be
like
the vice book and you're like the books
the books your face yeah the books of
face
the artist the hardest sell
well you know at least it ain't myspace
um let's get back to the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends i don't know maybe
we should go on myspace i'm just saying
um and that shows how how up to speed i
am uh number one in politics right now
child's is trending uh during the judge
tangy brown jackson supreme court
confirmation hearing senator lindsey
graham brought up uh
judge jay michelle childs he's really
butthurt that his pick didn't get picked
of course he's not the president united
states lindsay lindsey if you wanted to
pick if you wanted to pick the supreme
court nominee you should have won your
nomination and you should have won your
race i mean that's just the thing but
you didn't you suck he was you remember
this when there were so many republicans
they they had to have two sets of
debates and lindsey graham wasn't even
in the top tier do you remember that
yeah yeah he wasn't top billing for sure
right yeah yeah well that may be why he
he tucked elder uh run in and um he went
golfing with trump and decided trump was
okay after trump uh threatened
to uh maybe play some footage of him i
don't know maybe maybe not uh let's see
can we get a clip here let's see if we
can find a clip of what he was saying
earlier
uh about uh he was really crying hard it
doesn't look like anyone has clips yet
someone out there um now we've see we
see this changing katanji brown jackson
maybe we'll get some clips in here of
lindsey graham crying about how brett
kavanaugh had it so rough did you see
have you been watching this morning i've
been watching a little bit i watched
earlier where uh feinstein was talking i
heard a little bit of grassley uh i
heard a little bit of uh
corin
and he was like we got to protect the
freedom to bear or the right to bear
arms like the only two what the only he
was he was talking about like judges and
having the responsibility to protect
certain rights and he was like
right out of the gate he was like we got
to protect the right you know to bear
arms and also our religious freedom and
i was like so again you guys really
doubled down on first and second
amendment you cannot bring up any other
amendment or any other reason why
supreme court would need or like a
justice would need to be
in office on the bench
you guys only rely on
the second or the first and the second
amendment that's all you guys have you
cannot quote another one well you know
what's funny is this [ __ ] idiot chuck
grassley here no we can't see the man
alive a man if you want to look up his
birth certificate
his uh or his birth certificate yeah he
doesn't have one but he has a social
security number and it's one that's what
zero zero zero zero zero one is that
right like the very first one or yeah
like it is the original like the first
they're like oh we should probably start
like numbering people and then he was
the first one that got it he also got
all the shots too so just pointed that
out there at all the shots
all the shots like all the vaccines oh
yeah yeah so was he the first recipient
of like like every vaccine since he's
like the number one number they would
they put him
you know that may be why he's still
alive i mean it's a possibility
that his series says that this is the
face of a black woman already over the
shenanigans
it's also the face of a black woman
already formulating how she is going to
handle all this hot garbage
she is built for this we are built for
this event nicole brown she's great yeah
she is she is and and thank you uh let's
retweet here and give her credit um you
know i wanna i want to say something on
this and i know we've talked about it a
lot here on the show is that
i i think i i cause i've said that i
think america
um
as as katangi brown jackson which she's
going to be the supreme court justice
there there's no question here i mean
she has the most experience she's super
qualified right she's a you know woman a
person of color like there's no re like
outside of the obvious which is like i'm
an old white dude and i don't want
people who don't look like me on the
bench right kind of thing uh that's the
that's the only thing they they can
that they're able to lean on but they
can't use that so they're gonna have to
come up with some [ __ ] reason and
it's gonna be [ __ ] all right well i
mean uh
chuck grassley looks at a nominee like
you don't have an old wrinkly republican
nut sack like me then you're not
qualified you're not qualified does your
chin sack match your ball right right
right but here's here's the point i want
to make here about this this image right
is she is going to be the first black
woman to be a supreme court justice and
the reason why joe biden made that
promise to america
is because he wants the supreme court as
do a lot of americans
want the supreme court to look like
america right like we want it to you
know you look at it and you're like
again oh it's not all wrinkly republican
white ball sex like it is it is it looks
like america it's diverse enough it
shouldn't look like the top one the the
elite you know the supreme people it
shouldn't look like that it should look
like how actual america is right
and that's the most important thing and
i think like if we can't expand the
court you know
however we
decide on that one later on at least we
can get proper representation so that
when cases come through
their docket and they actually sit on
the bench and and decide on them that we
actually get the actual voices of the
actual people of america
to be represented you know well you know
the reason why i think
chuck grassley and josh hawley
specifically josh holly really is
completely obsessed with porn he loves
porn he loves po he's really obsessed
he's he's got those tabs always just
like porn porn porn porn he can't stop
talking about it but the reason why
specifically uh josh hawley is very very
very big jelly of katangi brown jackson
here's why
in this country a black woman has to
work about five
hundred times harder than any white man
would ever dream ever dream of [ __ ]
working right they have to do well in
school they have to do not just
elementary but middle school high school
college
law school they have to do 500 times
better than any [ __ ] white man would
dream
right of of having to do
here's the problem with that is you have
you have such a [ __ ] worthless piece
of [ __ ] like josh holly who doesn't even
live in the state of missouri who
represents the state of missouri going
to attack katangi brown jackson for a
thing like child porn when he's the one
who was completely obsessed right born
completely obsessed with it
and the reason why is because
he is so ineffective and so inefficient
that he doesn't even understand doesn't
even understand how hard it is for a
black woman to get in the seat that
katangi brown jackson is in today right
and i'm telling you they are fearful
they are fearful because they know that
fact josh hawley knows that katangi
brown jackson didn't just
lump her way through school and didn't
just just lollygag around in her career
that's not what happened at all she's an
actual [ __ ] judge right she's been in
trials she has made decisions as a judge
in the district court
they that terrifies them that terrifies
them and it should terrify him because
black women are the most educated
demographic in this country they're the
most educated
really honestly they're the most
qualified to be judges to really be
anything in any professional career to
be honest with you they're the most
educated uh demographic in this country
and i would even say they are also a
group of people who have the the the
experiences that can
reflect
you know properly of one
the american situation in terms of
people's life right like how hard you
have to work how many jobs you have to
work you know what it takes to work
through certain socio-economic
situations you know nothing that josh
hawley mr i went to an ivy league and
i'm a lawyer and i support [ __ ]
white people like josh hawley is
is a nazi oh right yeah yeah he's a i
mean he's a nazi let's just call that
right right uh come at us bro uh but
what i will say is josh hawley is
another person who sits as a as a
lawmaker at on capitol hill who has not
worked
for his job he has not had to prove
himself right he doesn't even have to
live in the state that he represents
right which is ridiculous and also a
theme within the republican party
but you look at josh hawley and that guy
has done nothing like i want i would
love
to if someone could prove i'll put down
put down money for you to prove that
josh hawley has ever worked for
something in his life and has not been
given that thing has not been assumed
the privilege of giving that role or
that responsibility or just says yeah
well i know so and so so they vouch for
you so yeah come on yeah you know like
that's what it is as opposed to being
one a woman in this country where you
already have to work even harder and
being a woman who is a person of color
where you know you have to work as you
said 500 times harder where it becomes
almost impossible because you're
competing against a bunch of old white
men who are afraid that they're going to
become irrelevant
and then they cry about how oh it's not
fair that i didn't get to choose this
person or whatever like it's just
non-stop
crying complaining
incessant whining that they don't get
what they want even though we've had
hundreds of years of this [ __ ] and
clearly it hasn't worked so [ __ ] needs
to change
you know i i want to be fair to joshua
you said he's never worked for anything
in his entire life i do want to say that
there is a picture of him out there
kissing his wife and he worked very hard
very hard in that picture to try to look
like
he really wanted to kiss his wife i
don't know i'm just saying that's what
the picture looks like to me oh i
thought you were going to say something
else
well yeah right well what what did you
think i was going well i just thought
you were gonna say like he worked very
hard
to convince her yeah
to you know it was like incessant
whining and complaining for him to be
like please go out with me please go out
with me please go out with me and it's
like please marry me please mary please
marry me you know right so you're are
you saying that josh
josh holly shaves but he he has a beard
is that what you're saying
yeah i just think that he is someone who
uh again assumed
uh
assumed
that he
would be
uh
uh
he would be the recipient of whatever he
walked into right like he was like even
even a kiss even a kiss right exactly
he's like i deserve this kiss you're
right i deserve this wife right no josh
holly right right right rf and dick well
that's how they did uh midas lisa thank
you for the super chat 100 episodes
thank you even though you said you're a
little late here but we love having you
and that is the nice part even if you're
late
it's okay because you can subscribe to
the youtube channel
just just search the tony michaels on
youtube
or you can go to thetonymichaels.com you
can follow all the links there whether
you're watching on facebook you can go
to youtube
and you can re-watch you can re-watch
every single episode on the youtube
channel as long as they don't take them
down i think there's a few of them that
are banned um videos
well uh earlier episodes
i may or may have not said some [ __ ]
about you know like um
you know like the pandemic and stuff and
they they they rip those videos down i
think i have one like the uh warning
strike or what are you an anti-vaxxer
are you in no no no no no no i was i
what happened was i believe in that
episode now you can go listening to it
on the on the podcast so go to
thetonymichaels.com
you can go to all the directories even
the boycotted ones spotify
um if you boycott that you can still go
there and listen to it um apple google i
heart radio all the directories your
favorite directories it's on there
but i and i have to look up what episode
it is but i believe what happened on the
episode
is i was mocking what the anti-vaxxers
would say and i think they thought i was
saying it and then my appeal
you know presented that
they still sarcasm and satire and parody
are sometimes hard to decipher
especially in text but if you're if
you're selling it pretty well tony well
you know sometimes the way i look and
sound it sells it very very well so um
here we have we have the uh thread of
josh holly
uh starter kit
uh huh is that a is that is that a merch
area i don't know don has it here um
he's pointing out to uh benny thompson
here
don winslow says josh hawley is selling
merchandise oh right property off his
rule on january 6 while your committee
won't even subpoena him
uh it's sometimes and you know how i
feel about this this stuff about about
don wenzel going after the the select
committee
but i will i will agree with him that
this is kind of gross um we have josh
holly here
selling he's actually selling like this
that's that's the grip he uses when he
watches porn
is that is that him trying to show
people how hard you're supposed to grip
or yeah that's him going tight grip
white knuckle uh uh josh hawley i don't
want it one is when his wife is like no
we're not doing that and he's like
gotta really yeah so is that that he
really really gets it out you know but
this nazi you know i've always said
about this picture because this this
picture is gonna live in infamy right
yeah yeah like
i've always said about this picture
about josh hawley adolf hitler would
have been really disappointed in him
like you really got to straighten your
arm and really get your fingers out
there josh yeah maybe maybe he's not
like
like i don't know tennis elbow or
something you know you can't go all the
way but but really that hey hitler adolf
would be very disappointed in this in
this uh this gesture here but anyways he
thinks it's so cool that he actually
sells merchandise with it on which is
kind of [ __ ] gross um
so uh let's see here
we seen this video earlier um
christopher says josh holly right now
yeah
uh
let's see what's what's chris say here
josh hawley's attacks on judge brown
jackson is nothing more than
race-baiting
sadly it's good also good politics for
potential
gop presidential primary so
chris here is assuming
that josh hawley is going to run for the
president united states which i would
welcome to be quite honest with you but
um he's assuming that he's going to run
for president united states what do you
think do you think josh hawley
uh thinks he could be president of the
united i mean he can't even live here in
the state
i believe that josh hawley believes that
he should be president i think he i i
think that josh hawley looks at himself
and he goes yeah i earned it
definitely could be president i should i
should be yeah he goes he goes i should
be the president you know and he'll
eventually he'll straighten that arm out
but is this is this before before or
after he does his morning pornhub
routine i think he he pumps one out
right and then he goes out and says
i should be present like every day maybe
that's what he does is that is how he
say i should be president
i should he looks like he looks in the
mirror and everything i want to be
president
every morning he looks in the mirror
after he's while he's doing it and he's
like i should be president i should be
president i should like oh yeah so you
think you think like that's that's what
yeah oh i think why not like it's like
presidential porn type stuff yeah yeah
yeah it's a it's a whole fetish thing
does he play the music
yeah yeah well you know what i think he
does that but he also could play what's
that song that trump plays when he goes
out to all his rallies um do you mean
you mean the the ymca
in america oh oh yeah yeah
oh okay you mean lee greenwood yeah
whatever i don't know yeah yeah see i'm
yeah yeah oh okay well you know yeah but
he's a piece of [ __ ] yeah every everyone
is saying in the comments that they
don't the crowd here doesn't like josh
holly very much uh which is not
surprising most people did anyone really
like josh holly though
i don't even think his wife likes him
look at ted cruz his wife and his
daughters don't even like him
like you got you got to look you got to
look at the republican party and say
if your family
like i i used to work with rick scott's
daughter
and she doesn't even like him
okay so it's like you there is something
to say against republican uh
families but their republican fathers
their kids
don't like their fathers right well
so there is hope there is hope that
somewhere in that family lineage they
can break off and make a difference in
society well yeah
i think so right now the only thing
we've heard is like you know certain
people speak out or certain people who
show i mean like it's it's real awkward
and real obvious when you see footage
and they're like going for the hug with
the kiss and the christmas like
you know right you're like you don't
wanna
well i mean even josh ollie is that way
with his wife
and i can't even imagine having a
picture of rick scott kissing anything
oh
[ __ ]
there's that there's that photo of rick
scott where he's laughing he's like
do you think he kisses with that open
mouth oh my god oh probably there
that's scary as [ __ ] okay i said this
morning about josh holly um i'm just i'm
just asking questions here i asked you
questions that the american people want
to know because of them why is josh
holly so obsessed with child porn maybe
we should check the repair shops for his
laptop i'm just saying
i'm just saying that maybe just maybe
there's a reason why josh hawley is so
obsessed with porn and champ i mean i i
don't know it
maybe maybe we could get hunter biden's
laptop's take on it maybe maybe hunter
ben's laptop is going to hold a press
conference uh about josh hawley's laptop
i don't know i'm just saying
i'm just trying to point that out now
let's see what else we got here um
amy here says heads up republicans will
attempt to blame
judge brown jackson for the entire state
of crime in the u.s because she was a
defense attorney
his perspective which is greatly needed
on the supreme court
they've already started with false
accusations see holly missouri
um this is another other than the the
the porn thing because they're trying to
they're trying to make bones out of the
porn because of the q anon thing right
they want to try to draw in this whole q
anon conspiracy theory into this hearing
um because democrats actually questioned
the accusations against brett kavanaugh
the sexual assault allegations against
brett kavanaugh because they actually
questioned that criminality now that
brett kavanaugh participated in i i
believe it's true i mean the evidence it
pretty well showed it um also i want to
know who paid off brett kavanaugh's
debts when i i am buying millions of
others also wonder that too right
but we have josh hawley not only going
to question um her sentencing of of of
child pornographers i guess that's where
they're going with it but also they're
questioning that she was a defense
attorney that she defended someone as a
lawyer the lawyers defend people they
defend criminals like that's like you
actually even if you are a criminal in
this country
even if you've committed the crimes that
you were indicted for you still are
entitled
as your right
to a defense now some people more than
others in this country people who look
like me are way more entitled to a good
defense than than others white men are
way more entitled to illegal defense
than others in this country
which is a thing that needs to change
and that's the whole reason and i think
that's what amy is saying here is that
hey that perspective needs to be on the
supreme court
that there are there are injustices
inside the defense attorney realm of
criminal justice
that people aren't defended well because
i believe that there's a lot of people
in this country
that aren't defended properly whether
they're the criminal or not rather they
actually committed the crime or not
everyone is entitled to a defense in
this country in a court of law and they
should get that and and um
we should be careful when we accuse
attorneys of being criminals because
they're defending them um and that's
what they're going to try to do and it's
going to be it's going to be all the old
racist tropes here um that's what
they're that's again what she's saying
here i think is to the race guard of a
black woman must be a criminal angry
black woman must be a criminal i think
is um what is uh probably going to ensue
especially from uh josh holly that yeah
and i think the the other thing you know
that they're gonna they're gonna play up
is
court packing right they're gonna
they're gonna say well she supports
court packing that's gonna create an
unfair advantage for the democrats to
really have a stronghold on how we
create laws or precedent in this country
like i guarantee
you know i've already seen mitch
mcconnell pull that way where he's like
not in support of her because her her uh
her her thoughts are or comments on
uh expanding the court so there's
they're they're making they're
they're trying to make uh
something out of nothing
and that's what it's coming down to
right they're like if we can't attack
her legitimately
for her record then we got to make stuff
up
and we got a misquote and we got to
mischaracterize and we gotta
decide that the reason we don't support
her
uh you know publicly is not because
she's black it's because of something
else but privately it's because
we're afraid
we're threatened you know um and that's
what it really comes down to
uh kathy thank you for the super sticker
there yeah thank you very much everyone
remember on youtube
you can do you can do super stickers or
super chats so thank you to kathy and
everyone who's done a super chat today
thank you very much for joining us
um here's a here's a good tweet about
josh hawley
anthony schnark says
josh hawley doesn't like black women
what's that called what is that called
what's that called i can't remember it
i don't know gabe what do you call that
can you can you uh get on your google
machine and uh look that up there and
see how you can figure out what yeah oh
you know what i didn't even have to type
it in google immediately shut it down
and said racism oh oh josh holly's a
racist no way
no [ __ ] way that couldn't possibly be
he's a white supremacist
what the [ __ ] okay yeah you know he's
been tweeting a lot lately about
kentangi brown jackson i don't know if
you see all these tweets from josh
hawley uh i am gonna go to one here i
don't normally do this but i'm gonna
show you the one where he is completely
[ __ ] obsessed with child porn if i
can find it back please show
i clearly see some of these uh previews
coming up where they're talking about
porn and darwin this is this is uh
uh march 16th this is josh holly all the
way back on the 16th preempting this
i've i've i don't know maybe maybe um
here
let me do this with you i've been
researching the record of judge katanji
brown jackson reading her opinion he's
he's reading he's reading her opinions
gabe
can you believe that he's actually
reading oh my god articles
interviews and speeches i think you need
to crack your voice a couple times i've
noticed
an alarming pattern now you just sound
like an old woman oh i'm sorry okay
you got it
uh maybe maybe i'll try to he's he's
pretending he has a d voice i've noticed
that alarming pattern when it comes to
judge jackson's treatment of sex
offenders what does that mean i think
what he's saying here
um because he said he read her opinions
articles interviews and speeches
um this is he didn't say writer's
sentencing i think that's what he's he's
trying to get at here is that she was
soft on crime you know that's the old
tour yeah she's immigrants
yeah he's trying to say
you know what's wrong in this country
these democrats and these democrats are
allowing sex offenders to
to run the streets run good luck and do
this right allowing sex offenders like
josh josh hawley and matt getz to just
run out the streets and god forbid we
look within ourselves and our own party
to just to determine that oh my gosh
this person running the sex trafficking
ring was a republican this other person
claiming to adopt a bunch of children in
europe was a republican actually was
involved in the sex trafficking ring
like all of these things you look at
it's like
the
the projection they have towards others
they're like look over there look over
there look out there they're the ones
doing it and they're like okay
like trying to like brush it under the
rug while they blame someone else for
something that has nothing to do with
that right well i mean i mean this is
the this is the whole republican way in
our day and age uh everything is
projection um it's the it's the trump
cult it's the way that trump rolls
uh he's always rolled with projection
and that's the way it's gonna continue
um but josh holly is completely obsessed
with child porn your tweet sucks they're
joshy
uh it really sucks of course i want to
tweet this
for new listeners out there um and
twitter always ask me if i want to tweet
obscenities or not and i definitely do
100 definitely want to of course he has
a whole also like what is the obscenity
there is that shitless and sucks yes i
think i think they do it for if you look
here i think it sucks
right i don't think it's [ __ ] i don't
think they get their their their you
know their thing out of whack because of
the [ __ ] i think it's the
the sucks
yeah
but you know what i don't know not only
does josh holly's tweet sucks
but he [ __ ] sucks i think you gotta
run gabe yeah everyone everyone stick
around uh we'll be right back
with the shitless roundup right after
this break thanks gabe
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number some patriots
ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out of natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
your absence i discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears tammy
[ __ ] him
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
the tony michaels podcast second hour
for all the new listeners out there we
do two hours
two full hours every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific youtube
twitter twitch and now
today with episode 100 we are on
facebook that's right we are on facebook
today
you can go to midas touch facebook page
we will be uh
broadcasting live
every single weekday from that facebook
page i mean
as long as as long as i don't get kicked
off facebook i don't know that's
probably why i haven't been on facebook
much and maybe i'll uh end up in jail
over there
maybe i'll end up in jail i don't know
who knows who knows what could happen
but join us every single weekday or
monday through friday noon eastern 11
center right here on youtube twitter
twitch and now minus touch facebook page
as you guys know we're partners
distribution partners in association
with midas touch and we want to thank
the mizellas brothers
for helping us out get the message out
there
we're gonna go through more of the
shitless roundup
the tweety tweets and trendy trends
uh for everyone new that's listening
here's what we do two hours every single
weekday
we we generally go through the tweety
tweets and trendy trends
uh to keep everyone uh up to speed on
what is happening currently because you
know the new cycle is about five seconds
long and really it's getting to where
it's about three seconds long
in today's age so we try to keep you up
up to date on the pro-democracy
commentary
with a little bit of gusto maybe the
f-word every once in a while every
[ __ ] once in a while we'll throw in
the f-word um that's that's one reason
why maybe
facebook won't like us i don't know is
is there is there a way
um
does facebook ban the f word i don't
know twitter twitter twitter definitely
not questions when i use the f word but
they've never they've never put me in
jail because of the f word i think it it
depends on how you will use the word
[ __ ] right like [ __ ] is such a diverse
word you can you can use it in so many
situations and as long as you're not
using
uh the word [ __ ] as a threat right
as long as you're not using it as a
threat yeah you should be okay on most
social media platforms
some like it some don't um
but you know
maybe just maybe facebook won't i don't
know we'll find out in due time
maybe i'll get the phone call from the
suits so we can't stream you over there
anymore
you're way way way too off the map for
facebook
i don't know
we'll see we'll see so thanks for
joining us all you new listeners out
there on facebook again you can if you
miss the episode or you don't catch the
whole thing you can subscribe to the
youtube channel
you can just find us and just go type in
the tony michaels on youtube or
the tony michaels podcast or you can go
to thetonymichaels.com
the link is in my bio
i have a facebook page by the way um you
can it's facebook slash
facebook.com thetonymichaels and it's on
the tonymichaels.com you just go to
thetonymichaels.com
and all the social media links is there
now i don't post on facebook i learned
something
about uh meta universe if you post over
on the instagrams the grammy grams you
know as they were i'm trying to learn
how that works over there with the grams
but if you post a gram on the insta is
that how you say it if you post a gram
on the instagram i don't know i don't
know what it's called but you post a
gram over there
you can put it on facebook so the stuff
that shows up on facebook is the stuff
i've posted over on on insta instagram
now i will be commenting and sharing our
broadcast here every day on that page as
well so if you want to go follow me on
facebook uh just go to
thetonymichaels.com all those social
media links are there you can go follow
us on youtube twitter twitch also we do
a bonehead of the week poll if you guys
are interested out there it's at
tonymichaelspod on twitter we do a poll
on twitter every single week for bone
end of the week i would imagine
that a lot of these gqp senators
um that are going to be questioning
asking really stupid [ __ ] racist
questions
to judge brown jackson this week
my guess is
we'll probably end up having at least
one or two senators on the bonehead of
the week list and here's how bonehead of
the week works for all our new listeners
you go over to twitter you take the poll
right we have three contestants every
single week for bonehead of the week
when we put the poll out and you're
you're able to vote on who you want to
be bonehead of the week and then on
fridays in the second hour of the show
we break down the bonehead of the week
who won who didn't win why they were on
the list we also have some dishonorable
mentions and alpha cuck of the week also
on bone head of the week
so go check that out and stay stay with
us
stay listening we appreciate all the new
listeners
everyone's here today
old and new
uh let's get back to the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends um you know that a
lot of a lot of the judge brown jackson
um confirmation hearing is trending
right now
um i want to try to find a picture
all right excuse me a uh
lindsey graham is trending with childs
um
he was really concerned about how white
men are treated in this country how
white men have to be held accountable
when they sexually assault someone and
want to be a supreme court justice he
was really really concerned with that
now mayo makes a really good point here
lindsey graham can eat [ __ ] that's a
really good point
like um i don't know if you're gonna
find a better
[Laughter]
i don't know if you're gonna find a
better argument
than that thank you mayo um mayo if
you're not following me oh you know
she's on instagram too now you go follow
me on instagram just a shout out to the
mail on instagram trying to get her some
instagram followers um i'm trying to
find the the video
um
oh this is this is video from the uh um
when he was all pissed off about brett
kavanaugh let's watch this here what you
want to do is destroy this guy's life
hold this seat open and hope you win in
2020. you said that yep
you're right you're correct
you're you're correct
not me
you've got nothing to apologize for
when you see sotomayor and kagan tell
them that lindsay said hello cause i
voted for them
i would never do to them what you've
done to this guy
this is the most unethical
sham
since i've been in politics
and if you really wanted to know the
truth you sure as hell wouldn't have
done what you've done to this guy i hope
the american people can see through this
sham
oh he's being a white man being held
accountable for his actions
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
yeah canada hates trump says
i wonder if lindsay this is the this is
the
the tweet above this um
this video i just showed i wonder if
lindsey graham is going to show as much
passion and emotion during the scotus
confirmation hearing for katangi brown
jackson as he did for frat boy rapists
and beer guzzler brett kavanaugh
yeah
i would imagine
i would imagine
not
imagine not i would imagine that's
probably not gonna happen
okay let's see here
um here it is here it is and now the the
footage is starting to uh work its way
on twitter uh this is uh lindsey graham
saying
says calling republicans racist is not
going to fly with us
because they're used to it let's see
let's see what he says remember
he didn't make the cut
well-lived life just completely ruined
so if you're hispanic or
african-american conservative it's about
your philosophy
now it's going to be about the historic
nature of the pick
it's going to be about your philosophy
the bottom line here is when it is about
philosophy when it's somebody of color
on our side
it's about we're all racist if we ask
hard questions it's not gonna fly with
us we're used to it by now lisa
we're used to it we're used to being
racist by now i mean you know it's a
thing that we do so why not why not
we're used to being racist by now
no [ __ ] lindsey graham
jesus
you can't make this [ __ ] up you really
can't
now let's see if there's any other
uh here here we go here's him whining
about kavanaugh and his opening
statement
um aaron's got to post it here to the
very last minute when the hearing's
about to be gavel concluded and say oh
by the way i've got this letter
and so happened that every media outlet
in the country had the letter too so the
next morning there were headlines all
over the country really accusing judge
kavanaugh being basically bill cosby
none of us are going to do that to you
that that the reason why no one is going
to con
going to accuse
katangi brown jackson
of sexual assault is because there is no
allegations you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
how can they not know this
how in the world can you walk
can you walk through this this timeline
that we have and realize that the reason
why no one is going to accuse or can
accuse
judge brown jackson of sexual assault is
because there's no accusations
and and
everyone's pointing out that notice he
uses bill cosby right that that's that's
also
a valid point
that's also a valid point
is the race-baiting
but the reason why no one is going to
accuse
judge brown jackson of what they accuse
kavanaugh of
is because there's no accusations
lindsay oh
white men who have accusations of sexual
assault against them have to be held
accountable well that's just [ __ ]
and if any of us does that to you
all hell will break out
and it should right look look at look at
judge brown jackson here
thinking
thinking the same things i'm saying like
the reason why you're not gonna accuse
me of it you dumbass this guy's never
sexually assaulted anyone
you [ __ ]
jesus
you can't make this [ __ ] up you really
can't
oh
thank you aaron for posting that clip
of lindsey graham saying the quiet part
out loud that brett kavanaugh was
accused of sexual assault yeah
that's
he was accused of sexual assault that's
why he was being questioned
as he was being confirmed for the
supreme court
seat yeah i would say there would be
questions about that if you had
accusations and i would imagine that
people would bring that up if if judge
brown jackson
had accusation but she doesn't
because she isn't
that's why it's so important not to
[ __ ] elect
a [ __ ] grabber as the president united
states
you want to know you want to know a big
reason why it's not such a good [ __ ]
idea to elect a [ __ ] grabber
as the president of the united states
the reason why it's important not to
pick a not to [ __ ] elect a scumbag
like that as president united states is
so he won't [ __ ] nominate scumbags
like brett kavanaugh to be on the
supreme court
you elect decent presidents you have you
what you have whoa here's a here's a
novel idea you elect decent a decent
person
as the president united states
you get
decent nominees for supreme court
justice and any other federal judge for
that matter we watched we watched the
scourge of vile pieces of [ __ ] become
federal judges under the trump
administration
a lot of them a lot of them barely had
their law degree
and we're becoming federal judges
absolutely ridiculous
oh yes um
i'm being told that this video
is a good video
um let's see here
let's see what this video is about here
looks like a brett kavanaugh video maybe
something about brett kavanaugh
uh let's see
let me take a wild guess here
you're bread right correct i thought so
um i got into yale law school
check out the big brain on brad
that's the number one law school in the
country you're a smart [ __ ]
that's right i had no connections there
i got there by busting my tail looks
like me and vincent caught you boys at
breakfast sorry about that
do you have it beer
i still like beer he's still like mind
if i have some of your tasty beverage to
wash this down sometimes i had too many
beers but i did not drink beer to the
point of blacking out
and i never sexually assaulted yes you
did
yes you did brett he is warm friendly
unassuming he's the nicest person i
don't remember asking you a goddamn
thing
oh i'm sorry did i break your
concentration oh boy
okay well um
i guess to break the mode there
let's see what else do we have trending
here um
of course you know there's going to be a
lot of bad takes on this supreme court
justice thing but i do i do want to
um from the republicans that is the only
good take is that she's [ __ ]
qualified and of course of course any
black woman in this country
who does at the level
of profession professionality
that katangi brown jackson has done her
entire career is qualified to be a
supreme court justice it just so happens
that the president united states the
decent
human being that we elected to be the
president united states picked a decent
human being and katangi brown jackson
and he promised that he would pick a
black woman so that way the court looked
more like america that was the promise
it had nothing to do it has nothing to
do with her color it has to do with all
the other justices on the court's color
dummies
so so nominating a black woman on the
court makes the court more like america
and there's
there's dozens if not hundreds of
qualified black women that could be on
the supreme court
itanji brown jackson just happens to be
the pic of president joe biden
so here we are and the only the only
really good take is that she's overly
qualified
overly qualified
so get over it you white ball sacks it's
going to happen um we've seen the number
13 boeing is trending uh a china eastern
airline plane carrying 132 people has
crashed in china's uh i'm not even going
to say it go on go i i don't know in a
region of china there you go and the
country state media reported so it looks
like
it looks like there is a 737 i'm gonna
quote the new york times here breaking
news a boeing 737 plane operated by
china east airlines
crashed in southern china with more than
130 people on board state media reported
there was no immediate information on
casualties or why the plane went down
so i guess the
the wonder is probably who is on the
plane um are they all chinese nationals
or is there americans on this plane uh
what happened to the plane uh was it in
operation what what what actually
happened
um so
uh we'll keep up with the boeing airline
crash uh let's see what else do we have
trending today
uh fetterman is trending in this state
the state of pennsylvania
apparently um there's a scuffle out
there between fetterman and connor lamb
um
a memo circulated by the pro conor lamb
super pac warns he's 30 points behind
that dim voters don't yet see john
fetterman as liberal
as the liberal he is
it also suggests that pennsylvania's
senator dem primary might get rough
it it shows a tax tested against
fetterman look
okay
here's the thing
is
if you're unaware of why primaries exist
democratic republican otherwise it's to
make sure that you get the best most
electable candidate right
conor lamb and john fetterman regardless
of which side you're on in this race
right regardless of which side you're on
in this race
you know everyone's going to say oh well
they're not liberal enough or they're
too liberal whatever the [ __ ] they're
going to say
look if you think conor lamb or john
fetterman
is gonna vote is gonna vote
uh
like
like mitch mcconnell you are a [ __ ]
idiot
you are a [ __ ] idiot right if you
think conor lamb or john fetterman is
going to vote with mitch mcconnell yeah
nope
but the people of pennsylvania the
voters in pennsylvania the democratic
voters in pennsylvania get to decide who
their nominee is and john fetterman and
conor lamb have the right
to show those people in a primary
and they'll vote
that's the greatest part about being
pro-democracy that really is the best
part about it is yeah democracy's hard
yes it is tough to keep a democracy
because you have to really [ __ ] work
at it but the greatest part about a
democracy and the greatest part about
being pro-democracy
is that in the end you really you really
can't
shake around
that it's what the people wanted that's
why i think we should encourage all
people to vote not just a certain
percentage of the population
i think we should have an opt-out system
for voting that's right opt out you
should have to register the vote until
you opt out
we should stop preventing people from
voting we should encourage more and more
people to vote i actually am glad to see
that new york the city of new york is
trying to get non-citizens to vote in
their city council
they live there they [ __ ] live there
they go to school there they work there
they have their trash picked up there
they drive the streets they walk on the
sidewalks they shop they pay taxes
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
if you don't think that someone has a
vested interest
in in this country or in a city or in a
county or in a state
it's people who live there
and the people who live in pennsylvania
i have full confidence
full confidence that those people in
those primaries those pro-democracy
voters
will go and they will have their voices
heard
whether it be for fetterman or for conor
lamb and i have very good confidence
that conor lamb and john fetterman will
definitely
definitely
work out this primary and who's going to
be voted for which
and honestly
everyone anyone who's scared of a tough
primary in pennsylvania
is not paying attention
listen what would you rather have in
pennsylvania would you rather have a
real good tough
fight of who's better conor lamb
or john fetterman and the entire state
knowing who the democratic nominee is
and that it was well fought
and those two candidates the best
candidate won
and that they get to go vote for that
candidate
for the primary or for the general
election in the midterm
because let's be frank
you know that's what democrats are
terrified of
they're terrified because we're such a
big tent party
they're terrified of the burning or bust
uh attitude
oh well if i don't get my candidate then
i won't vote
well that's that's what you gotta do
you got to make sure that everyone knows
what the risk is if you don't pick the
best candidate and if you don't go vote
for that candidate regardless if it's
your guy that won or not or gal
not in this case it's jon fetterman and
conor lamb
in some races it's going to be it's
going to be women who are going to win
those primaries
at the end of the day the point is is
that we have to vote pro-democracy and
we have to show
this country who the republicans are
they're showing you who they are they're
pro-putin
they're pro-putin and they're obsessed
obsessed with child porn
maybe because they're part members of
their party are going to be indicted on
federal charges for sex trafficking
minors
matt gatz maybe that's why josh hawley
is so obsessed with it
trying to distract from the facts that
are gonna happen
um okay so let's
let's go
let's see oh eric greitens is trending
oh nothing pleases me more than eric
greitens trending as you know eric
greitens is the uh the sexual assaulter
um the accused sexual assaulter that
once was the disgraced governor of
missouri he's now running
as a candidate for the senate seat it
looks like kyle griffin here has a
little bit of news
columbia missouri ap reports
ex-wife accuses missouri gop senate
candidate josh greiten all right excuse
me eric josh greitens
eric holly i mean it's like a one and
the same right eric greitens of physical
abuse and affidavit made public monday
uh oh
rot row
oh so what you say about eric greitens
is true
um and you got to remember this is the
republican party trying to run roughshod
over eric greitens they are terrified
terrified that eric greitens would win
the primary here in missouri
you know there was another primary in
missouri that's really famous
claire mccaskill
was running
uh running re-election for her senate
seat
and she was happening gonna have a run
uh against
um what claim to be moderate republicans
which is all [ __ ] moderate
republicans don't exist anymore inside
the gqp
but she was going to run uh supposedly
against modern republicans so what
what claire mccaskill did in all her
knowledge is she backed
with her money
and the most conservative quote unquote
the craziest the cutest of all the
republicans
which was todd aiken you remember this
name todd aiken
todd aiken was the was the [ __ ] that
said
well if if if it really is a legitimate
rape the female body has a whole way of
shutting that thing down you remember
that quote you remember that disgusting
vile [ __ ] that he spewed
now claire mccaskill didn't feed him
that line but claire mccaskill knew
knew that todd aiken had those views and
it was only a matter of time before todd
aiken would get out in front of a
microphone and say those views that's
why
she supported him in the primary
that's right claire mccaskill supported
todd aiken in the primary to make sure
that the crazy one would win
now a lot of people are terrified of
that fact oh my god we can't do that all
these republicans will elect these
crazies well that's not true
and we see that that's not true in a lot
of these school boards rates races
throughout the country
a lot of these two and honors these
[ __ ] bannon trader tvers you know
what i'm talking about
these people that would go to these
school board meetings and raise hell and
say all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] that
wasn't true you know they see our tears
the crt voodoo [ __ ]
right
they would run for school board and get
their asses kicked
and the reason why is because they're
whackadoos that know nothing about
education
and people in local races knew they knew
nothing about education
yeah they might they they might be b or
four against or whatever the mass
mandates were
in some of those school districts but
they knew
they knew that they couldn't put some
[ __ ] crazy in charge of education
like yeah maybe they the stance on mask
but they wanted their kids to get a
decent [ __ ] education these people
couldn't win because they were too
[ __ ] extreme their domestic terrorist
well when you have someone like eric
greitens
who is a uh accused
multiple accused physical abuser
like he is
boy it just may seem that a lot of
republicans
in a general election for a midterm for
united states senate seat might rethink
their opportunity
to elect someone who's a decent human
being
if you catch my drift that's why the
republican party in missouri definitely
doesn't want eric greitens to be their
nominee
now i bet there's a guy down in
mar-a-lago
that would love for eric greitens to be
his nominee
and really honestly there's no bigger
fan of eric greitens than mike pence
either
that's right
brian tyler cohen says new eric greitens
ex accuses him in court of knocking her
down taking away her cell and keys
physically abusing their kids and
threatening suicide if she didn't
publicly support him
during his 2018 blackmail scandal
he's currently the leading gop
brian you spelled gqp wrong missouri
senate candidate
now thanks for your tweet even though
it's gqp
eric greitens is a a normal
and a uh
a a very visible face on steve bannon's
trader tv he loves going on steve
bannon's trader tv like it's a thing he
loves to do
loves it um what a lot of people may not
know about eric greitens
and when he was the governor of the
state of missouri
and if you can call in that
um
eric greitens
was challenged by his own party
democrats didn't run anything in in the
state of missouri not a goddamn thing
right they didn't they didn't they
didn't have control over a goddamn thing
in the state of missouri
it wasn't the democrats that ran eric
greitens off it wasn't mainstream media
it wasn't the liberal cabal that ran
eric greitens off
i mean jesus christ even in the state of
missouri the republican party has all
the reigns now
has had
maybe will have other than this senate
seat there's a good chance
that this senate seat is up for grabs
that's why everyone's freaking out over
eric greitens being the goddamn
candidate
because he's likely to lose
because a lot of people won't go hold
their nose
and vote for someone who [ __ ] duct
taped his hairdresser to a goddamn
treadmill
and took naked pictures of her that's
right that's the accusations
and it wasn't it wasn't democrats
who did the investigation against eric
greitens when he was governor it was
[ __ ] republicans it was republicans
who who met
in an undisclosed location to hold
eric greitens accountable for his
actions not just his his sexual assault
and domestic abuse actions apparently
but also
his crooked
where he's money laundering money
through a veterans charity a lot of
people forget about that fact about eric
greitens
that's right
there were accusations that eric
greitens used
his veterans charity to to pocket money
personally
and launder money in his own pocket the
other way the other way is he used
the list that he gathered from that
non-profit in his campaign which is
illegal
those are the accusations
aaron greitens is
not the shining example of a decent
human being
by any stretch of the matter
the craziest part is when he when he
left being governor of the state of
missouri
somehow somehow
i'm not sure how
but he was awarded back his stance is
his position in the military i would
imagine it had something to do with
people at the white house or maybe even
the vice president united states at the
time mike pence
mike pence loves eric greitens oh loves
him
the other thing a lot of people don't
know about eric greitens
is there greitens in 2008 was on the
floor of the democratic national
convention
in support of barack obama
there you go trump supporters eat your
[ __ ] heart out
eric greitens of course of course he's
being accused of domestic abuse
he's the guy who duct taped his
hairdresser to a treadmill and took
naked pictures of her
that's the accusation
if you if you go back
maybe i'll find some links here maybe
i'll link to them on my twitter page if
you go back and you read this [ __ ]
story of what happened with eric
greitens and his hairdresser at his
house in st louis
how he he duct taped her to a treadmill
if you read that
just read that it reads like it's not
real life
i'm telling you go read it d can't look
away from this [ __ ]
you know democrats always want to look
away from this stuff progressives only
want to look away from this stuff that's
it's too graphic nope
you can't look away sunlight is the best
disinfectant and trust me with eric
greitens you need a hell of a lot of
sunlight with this idiot
we've already had a ton of sunlight so
much sunlight that he resigned as
governor of the state of missouri and
now he's a front-runner
for the senate seat
on the republican side and we've had
that much sunlight so much sunlight he
had to resign as governor but he can run
as the gqp senate candidate in the
republican party in the state of
missouri my great state of missouri
shouldn't be surprising can you imagine
oh that's so [ __ ] gross
eric greitens and josh hawley
are the senate delegation
in the united states senate for a state
uh
what the [ __ ] have we come to
what the [ __ ] have we come to we are 35
minutes into the second hour again if
you're new and you're just joining us
today we broadcast every single week day
noon eastern 11th century right here on
youtube twitter twitch and now
i'm now announcing today with the 100
episode we are broadcasting on midas
touch facebook page
as you guys may know we are um in
association with midas touch
they help us distribute our show we are
part of their network
now you got politics girl lee mcgowan
you got the weekend show with anthony
davis he got
the midas touch podcast with the with
the mizella's brothers jordy brett and
ben
you have legal af
with kfa and popock and then on weekends
you have been my zealous and bopak
you have kremlin files you have zoomed
in
there's all kinds of great stuff going
on at the minus midas media network
and we're we're the newest addition here
to minus touch so we're very excited to
be on the meta universe whatever that
means i think it's meta now it's not
facebook anymore right it used to be the
books of face now it's meta i don't know
i'm confused
very confused
let's go down to some more tweety tweets
attorney trains let's make this bigger
so you can see this um
baron is trending i think because it's
his 16th birthday
um i'm not even gonna go there but baron
is trending uh federal society is
trending
now it looks like sheldon whitehouse was
making some statements
uh maybe we'll uh
let's go down and see
if there's a video is there a video is
there a clip of sheldon winehouse
uh making making a point against the
federalist society probably
probably not yet we'll get there though
um it says here at the top senator
sheldon whitehouse makes a reference to
the federal society's influence on
supreme court justice nomination years
passed during the confirmation hearing
for judge katangi brown jackson
yes um sheldon whitehouse if you guys
haven't seen some of this stuff um
here's jennifer rogers
reporting um
white house not mincing words and going
after the federal society says jackson
is chosen on her merits not for
political reasons by a secretive
right-wing society
um so apparently i know i don't have uh
footage of it yet
here there's not a clip of it yet here
on twitter at least that i can find but
it looks like
looks like sheldon winehouse
in his true fashion
um
really dunks on the federal society
let's see if there's footage in the
videos tab did you guys know this on
twitter so you can do that look look
here
so if you if you search federal society
here it's got top latest people vid
photos and videos
to go over videos you can find some
videos maybe
um
of course i'm not seeing any uh
currently
any clips
of today's hearing where sheldon is this
it no that's october 13 2020. this is
where
um sheldon whitehouse is uh speaking out
against dark money actually you know
what this is a really good clip
um of sheldon whitehouse
talking about the federal society and
dark money let's watch a little bit of
this since we don't have a clip of what
he's saying today because it might be
relevant um what he's saying here to the
rest of today so let's watch
just a bit of this
when we spoke on the telephone
you were kind enough to hear out a
presentation
that i made
and um i intend to ask some questions in
that area
but it doesn't make sense to ask
questions if i haven't played the
predicate particularly for
viewers who are
watching this so
um
i guess the reason that i want to do
this is because people who are watching
this
um need to understand that this
small hearing room
and
the little tv box that you're
looking at um the little screen that
you're looking at are a little bit like
the uh
frame of a puppet theater
and if you only look at what's going on
in the puppet theater
you're not going to understand
the whole story you're not going to
understand
um
the real dynamic of what is going on
here
and you're certainly not going to
understand forces outside of this room
who are
pulling strings
and pushing sticks
and causing
the puppet theater to react
so first let me say why do i think
outside forces are here pulling strings
well part of it is behavior
we have colleagues here who supported
you
this nominee
before there was a nominee
that's a little
unusual
um we have the political ram job that we
have already complained of
driving this process through at
breakneck speed in the middle of a
pandemic while the senate is closed for
safety reasons
and while we're doing nothing
about the covid
epidemic around us
we have some very awkward 180s from
colleagues
mr chairman you figure in this
uh our leader
um said back when it was garland
versus
uh gorsuch
that of course of course the american
people should have a say in the court's
direction of course of course
said mitch mcconnell
that's long gone
senator grassley said the american
people shouldn't be denied a voice
that's long gone
so sheldon whitehouse here not only
pointing out the uh
the hypocrisy of the gqp but
also the politicization that they make
on every single seat that comes about
including this one with uh judge brown
jackson
that we're gonna see thank my thank you
minus ken for the super sticker really
appreciated that just to remind
everybody if you're on the youtube chat
you can do super chat or super stickers
so we appreciate all the support there
thank you ken um let's let's go back
here um
see if we can find
uh a a video of him today speaking and
you should really go look at that video
let me let me retweet that real quick
um
you guys go
watch this video
um it's part one there's a he gave a big
long speech
in the senate hearing of the nomination
of amy coney barrett when they rammed
when republicans rammed her through
uh let's let's refresh this see if we
can get um
[Music]
this is this looks like
this looks like from today
um it's on sheldon winehouse's
uh page right now
um he says
the present court is the court that dark
money built anonymous donations funded
the federal society while it housed and
selected
turn style right return style run by
dark money donors judge jackson is
before us on our own merit
not at the request of a secretive right
wing donor operation
so here is a clip of him talking about
that we've already seen dark money
groups
use dark money
to run ads
charging that dark money swayed this
selection
we are hearing that again today
ironic
when hundreds of millions of dollars in
right-wing dark money
built
the current
court majority
and still signals its wishes through
flotillas
of dark money front groups posing as
amiki curiae
i welcome the debate on these points
and
i look forward to hearing more from the
excellent nominee before us
um so uh
sheldon whitehouse uh calling not only
calling them out but challenging them
saying uh let's do this [ __ ]
let's have this debate because it's all
projection again every single time with
these people
every single time with these fascists
it's projection and really honestly that
that that is a lot of fascism
that is done
is
is that way
it's how it's that's how it's operated
so we will uh let's see if we can find
[Music]
there more footage here
of sheldon winehouse
in the hearing okay let's go back to the
tweet which i can't find any more um
footage there of
uh let's go to the for you we are uh 45
44 45 minutes into the second hour
um gorsuch is trending lindsey graham is
trending again uh republican senators
are trending of course this is gonna be
the trend today josh hawley's trending
all these all these these these white
wrinkly old republican ball sacks
that are wanting white wrinkly old
republican ball sacks to be supreme
court justices now you know plus amy
coney barrett i mean she's pro
she's pro republican wrinkly ball sacks
let's face it
um uh gorsuch is trending
it's probably because it's just in the
mouth
of these republican men
who are asking
the first
black woman supreme court justice
because that's what she is she is going
to be
the first black
woman as supreme court justice
and they're asking her questions
but hurt that
kavanagh barrett and gorsuch oh they
were treated so unfairly
uh let's see
let's see
um
here we go eli says holly it's hard to
argue that child porn guidelines are too
lenient
someone should alert holly to neil
gorsuch's views on that matter
oh
maybe that's why gorsuch is trending
and gorsuch's views or maybe his
leniency on child pornography
um could be a dug up
okay let's go back to the trendy trends
and the tweety tweets
of course um judge jackson's
still trending the supreme court still
training i believe this is going to be a
very big push this week um in these
hearings i don't know how many i don't
know how many hearings we have
i don't know how many hearings we have
this week
i know this is the opening but i i
haven't seen the schedule yet i did
listen to the opening statements
um durbin and grassley
and grassley really was uh upset if we
can find it here
if i can find the uh
the footage of it of chuck grassley
being very very very upset
he was very
very upset that that democrats see the
constitution as a living living document
really upset they hate that
i mean they hate that with a passion
these republicans i mean
that
the democrats pro-democracy people see
the constitution as a living a living
document
like one you can change and amend let's
see if there's footage of this idiot
saying this
i think it's very important
that we hear this if we can
um
let's see budget
that's just them walking in here we
go uh maybe this is it sarah reese jones
of um
politicus let's see
there are lots of problems with living
constitutionalism
in the senate here this is it living
constitutionalism is what he calls it so
what he's talking about is that he's
really [ __ ] butt hurt that the
constitution is a living document they
hate that they hate that the
constitution can be a living document
god why would anyone want to progress
from the late 18th century when the
constitution was written why would
anyone want to change that document and
amend it you know like the first one or
the second one that they always [ __ ]
and whine and
[ __ ]
complain about
why would anyone want to amend that
document let's listen to this [ __ ]
trash there are lots of problems with
living constitutionalism
in the senate
we spend a lot of time writing
legislation we argue over the language
we negotiate over how broad or narrow
certain provisions of laws should be
if
we can't convince our colleagues to
adopt all of our ideas
we have been known to compromise every
once in a while
we depend on judges to interpret laws as
we write them if judges impose their own
policy preferences from the bench and
essentially revise the laws we pass
it makes it imagine that imagine a judge
using their their own empathy right
to judge to judge the law that you writ
that's called checks and balances
what how in the [ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] did we get so stupid in
this country that people vote for people
like this old nutsac
chuck grassley he's the oldest human
being on earth
they complain about about jill biden
being sleepy old
and and and not coherent look at this
guy
but here chuck grassley is here
complaining about how the [ __ ] the
the constitution is a living document
complaining that's right he's
complaining that it's a living document
that's where they're at harder for us to
write good laws sometimes we need to
include a provision here's a good part
to get a colleague support
so let's back this up a bit
listen to the point he's about to make
okay
listen to the point
that this dumb [ __ ] is about to make and
this is republicans in a nutshell
especially right now listen to this
sometimes we need to include a provision
that's very broad to get a colleague's
support
if a judge rewrites the law later
because of vague notions about fairness
or equity or common good
that unravels all of our work
so what he's saying is you listen to
what he's saying is like if we write a
law and we make it so broad that it
doesn't include in equality and common
good
for the people and a judge decides that
now you're really going to have to make
sure it includes equality in the common
good
he's saying you unraveled
the work we did as a legislator
so the work they did as a legislators to
not consider the common good or equality
and a judge and a judge considers the
common good inequality
in a provision
that's a bad thing
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
chuck grassley
worried worried that a judge
in this country would consider
a quality and common good
[Music]
that's where they're at
that's where they're at they are worried
that a judge
would consider
the common good
and equality and undo the legislation
that they compromised on
even though the consideration for the
common good
and
and for equality was not considered what
a [ __ ] um
here's another clip
that recount has let's play this of
chuck grassley to see what he says
democrats
systematically voted against many
well-credentialed
nominees
that were diverse professionally
diverse geographically
diverse religiously
and rever uh
diverse ethnically
was it racist
or anti-gracious
what is racist
what is that is that a word listen to
this
or audacious is it racist racist or
anti-women for them to do so
i don't believe that it was
democrats did it because the nominees
didn't agree with living
constitutionalism
there it is again living constitution
racist
i guess i guess if either republican
party you don't want to be a racist but
you might be a racist
i don't know i don't know what he i
guess he's saying here he's saying here
that people because they're from because
white people are from different parts of
the country they're diverse
what what does that mean
if white people are from uh well
that white guy's from ohio he's much
different than the white guy from
indiana i mean that's diversity right
it's not racism
race
it's not racist
oh [ __ ]
and they give joe biden hell
for his oratory skills give me a [ __ ]
break
i'll
i'll give you joe biden and i'll raise
you chuck grassley for crying out loud
okay let's see here
uh is there any of course there's a lot
of clips of of chuck grassley saying
really dumb things in in previous um
in in in previous hearings confirmation
hearings
uh but you know that this is this is the
the trope that the the far left and
george soros you're gonna hear george
soros's name we've already heard it
several times they not already george
soros george soros is funding
judge katangi brown jackson
yeah
well
i guess that's where we are we're 55
minutes into the second hour thanks for
joining us at for episode 100 can you
believe that episode 100 is what we had
right here today on the tony michaels
podcast that's a big deal episode 100
and not only is a big deal that we have
episode 100
we today on episode 100 we streamed on
youtube twitter twitch and the midas
touch
facebook page
so be sure to keep watching us um if you
were out there on the facebook page
today keep watching us on the facebook
page if you want to follow me on
facebook you can go to
thetonymichaels.com
all the links are there you can follow
me on facebook instagram twitter
be be sure to follow
d tony michael's pod twitter page that's
where we do the bonehead of the week
poll every single week and there's gonna
be a lot of boneheads this week to pick
from trust me with this these with this
judge brown jackson hearing going on
plenty of heads to choose from so if you
go to twitter at tony michael's pod
you can follow the podcast there you'll
be able to vote it's voting practice
you know voting practice you get a
little practice voting on the bonehead
of the weak pole
so check us out there also subscribe to
the youtube channel don't forget we use
super chat in the youtube channel now
in the live chat you can live chat and
you can live chat with us on facebook
also on twitch as well twitter not so
much if you want to live chat with us
head over to youtube and you can go to
facebook you can go to twitch we'll live
chat with you there make sure while
you're there you like the video
give us a thumbs up
make a comment down below all that kind
of good stuff whatever whatever you're
supposed to say
whatever i'm supposed to say to get you
to comment like share all that kind of
stuff do that
do that i appreciate you guys joining us
for episode 100
it's been over a year now
and it's been i guess i i guess it's
been um
i guess it's been several several months
it's it's hard the time slips away
pretty fast it's been several months
since we did the podcast two hours a day
every single weekday we've been working
hard over here as you know you guys seen
gabe sanchez my executive producer and
co-host here on the show he works hard
every single week
to bring you great great interviews and
if you want to see a good interview with
gabe
uh he did a great interview with bad
brad berkwit
i i posted that on my twitter page
the link to the youtube um a
bad brad berkwith interviewed gabe and
released that episode last night we're
actually going to uh be recording with
bad brad he's going to come on our show
so be looking for that interview as well
um they're
bad brad is going to give you
a um a lowdown of this poster behind me
here
of sonny liston
and the champ muhammad ali he's got a
story about that that he's going to tell
us in the interview i believe
so be paying attention to that but go
over go over and check out that
interview with gabe and you guys will
learn a lot more about gabe than maybe
you already know on bad brad berkowitz
channel the ringside report
um just go follow brad
on twitter and also i don't know if you
guys noticed we had an
interview with anthony scaramucci
recently speaking of interviews check
out that interview
as well
go check out that interview as well with
anthony scaramucci
uh it's on the my uh midas touch uh
youtube channel it's also on our youtube
channel on the episode that we aired
last thursday so that would be episode
98 that anthony was um
was on so go check out that interview as
well go check out that
yes anyone anyone out there who has
helped with the podcast
here on the chat
on my twitter page you guys
um you guys have really
been the cause of all this i just
started talking into the microphone a
year ago
and originally when we first started was
just on wednesdays and i would do an
hour now just talking to the microphone
we wouldn't serve twitter or nothing
and then i got the idea late last summer
to start streaming and surfing twitter
and why you guys were surfing twitter
you know a lot of people watch video
games people play video games while
they're playing video games i was trying
to figure out what twitch was
and that's where we came up with this
that's where we came up with this
surfing the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends from
and it became a thing you guys liked it
i started doing it every single day
and then we had the podcast on
wednesdays we did bonehead of the week
on on the weekends so then we just kind
of mashed it all together and made a big
huge
um
[ __ ] sandwich as the podcast so every
every single weekday we do two hours a
day and really honestly if we get to
where we need three we may just do three
hours a day if we have to
this summer with the midterms yeah we
might have three hours worth of content
every single day that we need to get to
i miss a lot of stuff even with two
hours a day
but join us here every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central youtube twitter
twitch and now
now the midas touch facebook page
every single weekday
everyone of a monday through friday
check us out
don't miss it and until tomorrow until
tomorrow at noon eastern surf's up
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking